[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Norbert König ist mit mir im
Studio und du hast gleich zumindest eine
super Nachricht ja zu einem
einzigartigen Triumph in Manila der
andere die andere Nachricht ist
allerdings für den Betroffenen
Fußballlehrer nicht ganz so super guten
Abend dann blicken wir jetzt gemeinsam
auf unsere heutigen Themen
Kampf gegen die Zeit nach dem Erdbeben
in Marokko suchen die Helfer nach
Verschütteten für tausende kommt die
Hilfe zu spät
aus für Flick nach der Pleite gegen
Japan wird der angezählte Bundestrainer
vom Deutschen Fußball-Bund gefeuert
und Sieg für die Ewigkeit im Basketball
Finale schlägt das deutsche Team die
Serben und wird zum ersten Mal überhaupt
Weltmeister
der Norbert Basketball Weltmeister das
ist schon eine echte Sensation oder
absolut und die tut dem deutschen Sport
natürlich auch richtig gut allerdings
auf der anderen Seite gibt's nicht nur
diese Jubelbilder sondern eben auch mehr
zum Abschied von Hansi Flick das ist
nicht ganz so erfreulich vielen freuen
uns auf später
dreitägige Staatstrauer in Marokko wo
sie nach dem schweren Erdbeben
inzwischen schon über
2100 Todesopfer gezählt haben ebenso
viele sind verletzt hunderte gelten noch
als vermisst und es kommt jetzt wegen
der vielen verschütteten auf jede Minute
an das Beben am späten Freitagabend
hatte weite Gebiete im Südwesten
Marokkos erschüttert darunter auch das
weltbekannte Marrakesch das Epizentrum
lag 70 km südlich davon im Atlasgebirge
dort in der Provinz Alhausen gibt es
offenbar die meisten Opfer einer
Warsberg fast zusammen
will uns Ihr zu Hause zeigen das was
davon übrig ist mitten in der Medina der
Altstadt von Marrakesch sie und ihr Mann
haben es gerade noch rechtzeitig aus dem
Haus geschafft seitdem schlafen sie
draußen
ich war drinnen als ich um 23 Uhr ein
Geräusch gehört habe und gesehen habe
dass die Decke Herunterfallen würde und
sobald ich den ersten Fuß vor die Tür
gesetzt habe ist die Decke eingestürzt
sie fiel auf die Küche und das ganze
Haus
während hier die Aufräumarbeiten
beginnen bleiben viele Menschen draußen
aus Angst vor noch mehr Nachbeben und
keiner weiß wie einsturzgefährdet die
alten Häuser und Monumente jetzt sind an
der Moschee auf dem berühmten Marktplatz
dem Jamal lefnar ist ein Teil des
Minaretts eingestürzt weiter südwestlich
nahe des Epizentrums hat das Erdbeben
ganze Dörfer zerstört in der Provinz
Soldaten und Zivilisten Graben in den
Trümmern und hoffen Überlebende zu
finden
die Straßen sind blockiert und viele
Menschen können ihre Angehörigen nicht
finden da sind noch viele unter den
Trümmern alles ist hier eingestürzt die
Berge die Häuser da kommt man nicht mehr
durch wir müssen die Straßen erst frei
kriegen
die Einsatzkräfte und
Hilfsorganisationen können nur langsam
Vordringen in die entlegenen Bergdörfer
mit dem Nötigsten
Nahrungsmittel für die betroffenen
Menschen bereitgestellt wurden die von
der Regierung
[Musik]
spanien hat jetzt 56 Rettungshelfer und
vier Spürhunde ins Erdbebengebiet
entsandt
wir gehen live nach Marokko in der am
schlimmsten betroffenen Provinz ist eine
Arendt für uns eine fast 48 Stunden nach
dem Hauptbeben wie ist die aktuelle Lage
ja immer noch sehr bedrückend würde ich
sagen die Menschen haben Angst vor
Nachbeben sie haben aus draußen auf der
Straße im Staub und in der Hitze und sie
stehen auch unter Schock man muss wissen
die Provinz in der wir jetzt gerade sind
die hat weit mehr als 1000 Tote zu
beklagen und die müssen möglichst
schnell beerdigt werden so will es der
muslimische brauch gleichzeitig geht
unter den Trümmern die Suche nach Opfern
weiter noch immer werden Menschen
vermisst eine welchen Eindruck macht das
Katastrophenmanagement in Marokko auf
dich
also man hört dass es ziemlich
unorganisiert sei wir sehen zwar
Rettungswagen und wir sehen auch Militär
auf den Straßen aber zum Beispiel das
Dorf in dem wir jetzt gerade sind das
ist nur über eine Schotterpiste zu
erreichen und wir haben hier allenfalls
Privatleute gesehen die mit ihren Autos
sich hier durchgekämpft haben und Essen
verteilt haben auf einem Feld hier
unweit von uns da sind drei Frauen in
einem improvisierten Zelt sie sind
verletzt und sie warten immer noch auf
Hilfe also man kann schon sagen man
wundert sich ein bisschen dass hier so
wenig also eigentlich ja kaum
internationale Rettungsdienste zu sehen
sind und das stößt hier durchaus auf
Unverständnis vielen Dank für die
Schilderung live aus dem Erdbebengebiet
in Marokko an der Arend war das und wenn
sie den Betroffenen in Marokko helfen
möchten die brauchen ja jetzt jede Menge
Hilfe über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophe ist es möglich die IBAN dazu
sehen Sie hier
de
65-100 400 600-100 400 600 das Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Marokko und alle Infos dazu
auch auf spenden.zdf.de oder auf der ZDF
Text Seite 89.0
jetzt in die Ukraine bei einem
russischen Angriff sind nach Angaben
einer
Nichtregierungsorganisation 2
Mitarbeiter getötet worden zwei weitere
darunter ein deutscher wurden schwer
verletzt der Nacht hat Russland Kiew mit
Drohnen angegriffen die meisten konnten
vom Luftverteidigungssystem abgefangen
werden so dass Militär eine Person wurde
verletzt durch Trümmerteile wurden
Wohnhäuser beschädigt
der G20-Gipfel im indischen Neu-Delhi
ist zu Ende die Ergebnisse wecken wenig
Hoffnung im Kampf gegen Klimawandel und
Hunger spürbar voranzukommen und doch
haben die Staats- und Regierungschefs
Schlimmeres verhindert denn ohne die
mühsam gefundene kompromissformel zum
Ukraine Krieg wäre der Gipfel womöglich
gescheitert mehr von Roller
die G20 besucht die Gedenkstätte von
Mahatma Gandhi er war der Held einer
Nation eine Ikone des friedlichen
Widerstandes die indische Gipfel Regie
erlaubt dem russischen Außenminister
dabei zu sein der Gipfel hat Russlands
Angriffskrieg in der Abschlusserklärung
nicht verurteilt die Ukraine ist darüber
sehr enttäuscht
Bundeskanzler Scholz verteidigt im
ZDF-Interview die gefleck Ergebnisse
dass sich aus der Sicht der Ukraine da
noch mehr hätte stehen können ist
richtig aber die haben sich 20 Staaten
geeinigt und ich will das noch mal
betonen wäre es nach Russland gegangen
wäre das alles gar nicht so formuliert
worden sondern nur der Druck viele
andere hat dazu beigetragen dass das am
Ende auch gelungen ist der indische
Regierungschef inszenierte sich und sein
Land als aufstrebende Supermacht er
verhinderte dass der Gipfel scheitert
Band auch Russland und China ein deshalb
fühlt sich Russland nicht isoliert die
westlichen Regierungschefs erklärt auf
einer pressekon sei doch nicht so naiv
dies zu glauben denn die
Abschlusserklärung verurteile Russland
nicht bei dem anderen wichtigen
gipfelthema Klima sperren sich Indien
und China sie wollen fossile Energien
wie Kohle weiter nutzen eine Familie so
ist das Motto dieses Gipfels gewesen
doch diese gipfelfamilie musste viele
Konflikte unter den Teppich kehren ein
Formel Kompromiss beim Ukraine Krieg
verhinderte das Scheitern und beim
Klimaschutz gibt es Rückschritte das
Zepter bekam Brasiliens Präsident in
dessen Land der nächste Gipfel
stattfindet schon heute bei den vielen
Konflikten braucht er Durchsetzungskraft
nach Israel dort kam es erneut zu
landesweiten Massenprotesten gegen den
umstrittenen Umbau der Justiz allein in
Tel Aviv gegen gestern mehr als 100.000
Menschen auf die Straße am Dienstag wird
sich Israels oberstes Gericht mit den
Einsprüchen gegen die Justizreform
befassen schon Ende Juli hatte das
israelische Parlament für das Kernstück
der Reform gestimmt kritiker sehen
dadurch die Demokratie in Gefahr
bei einem Angriff auf vier Teilnehmer
des Christopher Street days in Halle an
der Saale ist dann 41-jähriger Mann
schwer verletzt worden nach Darstellung
der Polizei wurden sie nach der
Veranstaltung am Samstagabend von vier
Männern mit Tritten und Schlägen
attackiert die Polizei ermittelte zwei
Tatverdächtige sie sind 16 und 20 Jahre
alt
Kino am Lido die Filmfestspiele Venedig
zählen zu den bedeutendsten der Welt zum
Abschluss gestern Abend gab es den
Goldenen Löwen für eine schwarze Komödie
in pur things erzählt der Regisseur
Jorgos eine weibliche Variation über
Frankenstein als beste Hauptdarstellerin
wurde die 26-Jährige Schauspielerin
saily geehrt für ihre Rolle als
Priscilla Presley in der Filmbiografie
von Regisseurin Sophia
so und wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
Sport und auf diesen sportblock freue
ich mich heute ganz besonders ich auch
selber sogar die unglaubliche erfolgser
Geschichte wie wir sie erlebt haben
eines verschworenen Teams ist vollendet
der achte Sieg im achten Spiel ist der
wichtigste die Basketball
Nationalmannschaft feiert den ersten
Weltmeistertitel für Deutschland 83 zu
77 gegen Serbien
welch ein Triumph für das deutsche Team
hier feiert die beste und einzig
ungeschlagene Mannschaft dieser WM das
hier ist auf jeden Fall einer meiner
besten Momente in meinem Leben das mit
denen mein Thema zu feiern mit meinem
Code zu feiern in meiner Familie zu
feiern
wir haben Geschichte geschrieben und das
Endspiel an Spannung kommt zu überbieten
das deutsche Team im dritten Viertel
nach diesem herrlichen Spielzug mit 64
zu 53 Entführung zum ersten Mal
zweistellig aber sehr Bienen kommt
zurück auch dank Abramowitsch der
insgesamt 21 Punkte erzielt Deutschland
in der Schlussphase nur noch zwei vor
doch es kommt die Zeit von Dennis
Schröder der Kapitän zieht
unwiderstehlich zum Kopf 81 zu 77 enorm
wichtig 28 Punkte schafft er insgesamt
und ersetzt auch den Schlusspunkt 83 zu
77 und dann ist alles nur noch
grenzenlose Euphorie
Schröder wird auch noch zum wertvollsten
Spieler des Turniers gewählt ein ganz
großer Tag für den deutschen Basketball
[Musik]
tja bis zum fußball-weltmeistertitel ist
noch ein weiter Weg beim Fußball kam es
wie es wohl kommen musste die DFB
Verantwortlichen haben Bundestrainer
haben sie Flick und seine Assistenten
nach der eins zu vier Pleite gegen Japan
Zitat von ihren Aufgaben entbunden am
Tag nach der Blamage leitet er noch das
öffentliche Training es war sein letzter
Auftritt als Bundestrainer der nach
einigen Krisensitzungen und
Videokonferenzen im Team Hotel ist am
späten Nachmittag die Entscheidung
gefallen das fliegt gehen muss die Bosse
und DFB Gremien waren sich einig dass
die Trennung unumgänglich sei so die
Info in der offiziellen Pressemitteilung
die Mannschaft brauche Aufbruchstimmung
und Zuversicht so Neuendorf der seit
Wochen schwer angezählte flieg gab sich
gestern noch kämpferisch wir sind davon
überzeugt von dem was wir machen und ja
deswegen geht's auch so weiter für mich
es ging nicht weiter und voller
verzichtete bereits gestern auf ein
klares Bekenntnis zum Bundestrainer aber
wie im Moment wir tun gut daran erstmal
eine Nacht drüber zu schlafen bevor wir
jetzt irgendwelche Analysen machen was
zum Spiel Dienstag gegen Frankreich
werden Völler Hannes Wolf und Sandro
Wagner die Nationalelf einmalig betreuen
erst danach soll die Nachfolge von flieg
geregelt werden
dann hätten wir noch den
ruder-weltmeister Oliver Zeitler
Triathlet Patrick lange wird WM zweiter
eine Menge los an diesem Sport
vielen vielen Dank Norbert ja es bleibt
fast überall schön wir haben noch die
Wetteraussichten so sehen sie aus morgen
ist es war noch ein bisschen das ist das
Bild zunächst sonnig zum Abend bilden
sich dann schauen und Gewitter im
Nordwesten nordwestlich des Rheins
ungewöhnlich heißt bei 25 bis 34 Grad
ab 21:45 Uhr Bundeskanzler Scholz im
heute-journal Interview mit Maria Slomka
das war's schönen Dank schönen Abend und
jetzt direkt weiter mit Berlin direkt
und Theo